boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation i'm your host alan saki and
we are on site at the american
anthropological association's annual
meeting
we are now sitting down with dr debra
thomas thank you for coming on to the
show thank you for having me really
appreciate it i'm very excited we have a
lot to talk about deborah's background's
awesome all right here it is she is the
she's triple a's editor-in-chief of
their journal which is american
anthropologist she's a professor of
anthropology at university of
pennsylvania
core faculty and gender sexuality and
women's studies she got her phd from nyu
in 2000 and she's interested in
political anthropology sovereignty
violence after lives of imperialism
transnationalism diaspora race and
gender performance and popular culture
political economy
and the caribbean there's
what are you not interested in that's
the better question uh she taught at
duke for four years in cultural
anthropology
is it a four-time author ish
ish so many so many different
publications i'm excited to talk about
and also work on some film as well two
films
two films um
and she's the director of the center for
experi experimental ethnography um at
the university of pennsylvania which
opened just about six months ago
and it's right there so i'm really
excited to talk about all of this
and get to know you better let's let's
let's dive into
understanding you know who you are how
like who are you as a kid that led you
to become an anthropologist oh no
no i never woke up one day and said oh i
want to be an anthropologist i
completely fell into anthropology
um
i was a dancer actually i was a
professional dancer in new york for many
years and had been trying to think about
what's next
and the dance company that i performed
with which was urban bush women we did
we had a research to performance
methodology and we also did these
community-based projects where we would
work
with different grassroots organizations
in a city where we would go on some kind
of project that would use music and
dance to generate something else so
whether it was
you know
we worked in new orleans for example
with a basketball team that needed math
tutoring and so our task with them was
to up their grades in math
worked with a community bookstore in
some of their literacy programs we
worked with the welfare rights
organization on empowerment and knowing
you know knowing people's rights etc
so you know that kind of process was
really interesting to me because for me
dance had always been a way to
understand bigger political questions
about the worlds that we inhabit you
know
so i thought maybe i wanted to do
research like that but on a higher level
like what are the
are there situations in which that kind
of work was done not just at the local
grassroots level but at a national level
and
in jamaica dancers were very involved
with the anti-colonial project and so i
was interested in how they did that how
they attempted to transform people's
ideas about their own cultural practices
what was important about them
the institutions that they set up in
order to train young people in the
various dance forms that were no longer
just ballet and opera and classical
music but in fact had a grounding in
jamaican afro-jamaican tradition so
that's
how i ended up back in school but i had
applied to
i didn't know anybody who
had gotten a phd so i started polling my
friends and you know trying to find
somebody who i could talk to you know
about that and
eventually went and visited with a
friend of mine and you know one thing
led to another i ultimately went into a
latin american caribbean studies
master's program and one of my first
classes was with an anthropology
professor and i just like
fell in love good
well okay now as a as a dancer um
this is this is very interesting you
still dance today
not really like in the living room in
the living room with your kids exactly
yeah at weddings yeah likewise yeah
likewise
and stuff every now and then
but so teach us about you know
before we get to you know nyu and stuff
um
and
and even past that what
what was the
uh dancing for
anti-colonialism teach us about that how
does that what is that
yeah
well i mean i think you know throughout
africa some places in latin america
certainly the caribbean
and some places in southeast asia the
1950s and 1960s was really a time of
political ferment you know it was the
moment that
a lot of
nation states who had been colonized by
european countries were
questioning that political relationship
and were fighting to overthrow
colonialism in algeria that was a war
you know it was an actual fight like
that
in some of the british colonies it
wasn't
a military episode it was a gradual
process of transition toward
decolonization and independence
so one of the things
that happened in many of the british
colonial territories is that really
bright young people would get
scholarships to go
and study at oxford or cambridge right
and so there were a number of people who
had artistic training in jamaica and
ended up in scotland or england
and then they ended up learning folk
dances in english
and then they started to wonder you know
why don't i know my own folk dances we
must have folk dances in jamaica and so
for them i think it really started a
process of
questioning what they had been taught in
terms of the superiority of british
culture
and
you know
kind of provoked them to look more into
their own indigenous history and their
own
afro-jamaican traditions and to valorize
the african part of the afro-jamaican
which would then allow them to see what
are the practices that were brought
during the transatlantic slave trade to
jamaica adapted to the local environment
that really sustained people during the
period of slavery right
so they ended up doing a lot of research
into the history of those practices into
the ritual shape of those practices into
the rhythms and you know musical
instruments of those practices and then
for dancers of course into the
dances and so then they would take all
of that material and
transform it for a concert down stage
you know incorporating it into
performances
as the national dance theater company of
jamaica so it was really an attempt to
sort of change people's minds about the
values the value of their traditions
what
a unique way to augment perception
through through dance and theater um
and
especially because there is so much
richness in the culture of dance and
theater across the world but also that
there it's a very important story to
tell about what happened in the
transatlantic slave trade um
but the numbers are so huge it's like 12
and a half million
africans were moved across to
uh
all over all over yeah latin america
caribbean the united states
canada
yeah yeah and um
that's that i think that's the largest
migration a forced migration in the
history of the world i think
assume so yeah wow um
so
now okay now
as
it's like what do you
you know i mean the thing i think that's
special about um
theater also music also artistic
representation of visual art as well but
dance in particular
is that you know one stores memories in
the body you know and one
marks social relations and histories
through the body also so these dances
are not just sort of
movements undertaken for a kind of
ritual effect but they're also
you know a store
a storehouse of history it's an archive
you know it's an archive of
you know
personhood and archive of the history of
a community an archive of the social
relations of the community and also sort
of
life-sustaining
tools
you know in contexts of great
degradation so when people practice them
today
they don't necessarily know those long
histories but in practicing it they're
still participating in that tradition
not everybody still knows those
languages you know but in singing the
words they're still invoking that long
tradition yeah you feel it through your
body when you watch
we we had the pacific islanders in san
francisco doing their dance
and it was so
just the energy was so strong coming
from them and it was just sinking
through us and we were observing the
culture that has
that the dance that has progressed
through them over time and it's just
been it was very interesting yeah yeah
dance is a unique medium in that sense i
think so and like then there's like that
australia and new zealand have that
way is it just new zealand yeah has that
has that the the rugby games or whatever
they do that like not the like create
like like a very aggressive dance
there's that and then there's there's
yeah
so
okay um because i think we're actually
gonna end up talking about that
a little bit and more as as we keep
going on what what was your thesis on at
nyu
uh
my desert my phd dissertation yeah so it
really was about that you know what were
how were artists involved in these
anti-colonial movements what were they
trying to do
what kinds of institutions did they set
up in order to transmit that to other
people both in terms of the schools and
the dance comp the performance companies
or the theatrical companies
um
and then also you know how did that
change over time right jamaica got
independence in 1962.
the national dance theater company was
formed in 1962
but that practice in 1962 is very
different from what's going on in the
70s from what's going on in the 80s
what's going on in the 90s so i was
interested in
how new generations of performers coming
through might have configured their
purpose differently
and why you know what it was about the
changing reality on the ground that
pushed a different vision artistically
and also then
you know as artists i think we have
you know a healthy hubris about our
influence
in the world you know we feel like we
can change the world through art you
know and through performance but of
course many people remain unchanged so i
was actually quite interested in the
extent to which people who weren't
involved in those movements
really were attached to them you know
did it actually change people's minds
were people interested in these
afro-jamaican traditions which are
largely rural traditions you know what
people in the city do they care about
that you know and if they don't care
about that or if they only sometimes
care about it when do they care about it
you know is it only at independence time
where we have the national festival and
all the school children do their
performances or is there some other
sustained kind of relationship
and then if they don't care about it at
all what do they care about instead you
know so what do they feel actually
represents themselves as jamaicans
better than the national dance theater
company or better than what they're
learning at the school of art or yeah
you know and and what i've you know one
of the things that i found was that um
you know clearly by the time we reached
to the 1990s
um dancehall culture has sort of
taken over in terms of a public
expression for young people of what it
means to be jamaican you know it wasn't
really any longer these kind of country
traditions that seem to them to many of
them to be backwards you know not
something they would do every day but
dancehall you live every day you know
it's blasting from every car stereo it's
on every corner and the big speakers and
you know so that
um you know i was interested in how that
popular cultural representation became
the louder manifestation of jamaica
national identity by the you know by the
1990s early 2000s of course there have
always been popular expressions of
jamaican-ness right but um
easier to suppress
in earlier moments and i think by the
90s it was just
louder you know and there was no way to
really control it
as
perhaps people had tried to do in the
past and the
the theme of the dance uh was a lot of
the time anti-colonialism
well i mean that wasn't an explicit
theme in the dances per se though there
are certain
um pieces of choreography that the
national dance theater company of
jamaica did and developed that
um you know we're explicitly addressing
the political situation or telling those
that story of decolonization
but in their own research into the the
sort of traditional
afro-jamaican
music and dance forms all over the
island right because it's different
practices in different parts of the
island
that was a kind of anti-colonial move
because to that time for middle-class
people
you know dance was ballet
and you know you certainly didn't dance
barefoot and definitely there was not a
drum in the dance studio you know so
they really inaugurated a sea change in
terms of what was acceptable artistic
production on a concert stage you know
so that was a
you know it seems odd now because that's
so normal but at the time it was a
really radical
thing to do because it was changing the
cultural orientation of the audience you
know or it was intended anyway to change
the cultural orientation of the audience
and it grew a lot over 60 to 90s to 90s
just you said different parts of jamaica
picked it up and started having their
own sort of dance
well there was a
festival movement that really started in
the 50s right where
people in all the different towns all
over jamaica school children would
develop a dance or performance or
something that they'd compete then at
the local level at the parish level and
then those winners would come into the
city
around the time of independence and
there would be a big competition you
know and you would choose the best
the best dance the best monologue the
best play the best song you know those
kinds of
things and so that was one way that
people showcased you know what are the
traditions all over the island you know
but other companies style of dance
what there's lots of different stuff and
there's like you said there's they added
like a drum and that was new
and there's well it's new to middle
class people on a concert stage but
these traditions existed all over the
island you know prior to that but but un
unknown to many of the city people you
know unless they came from rural
areas so you know different forms in
different parts of the country there are
two areas of jamaica that are maroon
populations or maroon communities and
maroons had fought
for 150 years against the british army
and won and ultimately signed a treaty
with the british that granted them
sovereignty over their own land so those
folk have their own traditions called
coromanti and they have particular
rhythms that they play on the drums they
have a
horn which is called in a bang and they
have certain
things that are played on the bang and
different songs that are played but you
know in each pocket depending on where
people had come from and how they
adapted their traditions these kinds of
practices
developed and there's a practice called
tambu there's one called dinky mini
there's poco mania there's lots of
different
um things that developed both during and
after the period of slavery and after
slavery the sort of big one that
developed was called kumano
which is 450-year fight against
for for your land against the british
whoa 150 150 yeah what year did that
start
when did they sign the treaty is it
really most of the 18th century 1800 and
some of the end of the 100 british took
over um jamaica from the spanish in 1655
so sort of from
just past that period into the 18th
interesting
that's one thing about anthropology that
is ridiculous is just the amount of
complexity of people fighting for land
and
fighting wars for land and resources and
whatnot
um
okay so so now within the studies that
you're like really focused on uh
wait wait you had a period of time that
you were professing afterward at duke
right is that where you went after
after my phd yeah um not immediately i
went first i had a two-year
post-doctoral fellowship at wesleyan
university
which is in connecticut
so i was there at the center for the
americas for a couple years teaching
doing research etc
and then i got the job at duke and
cultural anthropology and so i was there
for four years
and then it was to university of penn
after that
interesting so
because that's been
you
how long has it been at penn now it's
like
we got there in 2006.
okay so 12 years there and four years i
do before that so it's it's a lot of
teaching that's like 16 years of
teaching i mean there are people here
who've been teaching for 50 years yeah
that's right there's lots of exactly now
now now teach us about what was
being taught what you were teaching at
duke and what you're teaching at penn
and
um let's ask about what you were
teaching first and then we'll ask about
like what what's been like with the
students as well sure
um
gosh i don't remember what i was
teaching at at duke
all the time um you know often i teach
an undergraduate class on the caribbean
you know culture and politics of the
caribbean
where we introduce students to caribbean
history and politics and economy and
they read ethnographies that are you
know contemporary ethnographies about
what people are doing research on today
i
taught a political anthropology class it
wasn't called political anthropology but
it's a class i also teach at penn it's
called race nation empire
we're really thinking about the
formation of the modern world
um
and how that's tied up with these
histories of imperialism and slavery and
racial formation
um
i teach intro now at penn introduction
to cultural anthropology and what does
one learn in in that class
well hopefully one learns something
about the diversity of
humankind and
learns something about
the way anthropologists have come to
categorize people
and the history of that and sort of new
ways to think about
those processes hopefully one learns
something about
the ways people organize their families
and how we think about some of the
classic themes in anthropology like
kinship or exchange
or cruelization
cultural contact you know how people
over the centuries have sort of
interacted with each other
over time
you know yes
classical anthropological yes yes
and and what about the current focus on
gender sexuality and women's studies
so what about what's really important
for
people to know about that today
oh it's such a huge field and such a
diverse field i mean my own interest
is always i mean i'm interested
not only in what women do which is often
how people think about women's studies
but in how all of the processes that we
study have gendered
dimensions and gendered effects so you
know i do a lot of research sorry i do a
lot of research on
violence and nationalism and
globalization so i'm interested in
how those processes also come out of and
mobilize or reproduce or challenge
particular gendered ideas about what men
are supposed to be like what women are
supposed to be like what men do what
women do
how families should be formed or not
formed and you know it comes into
contemporary issues for example related
to lgbt rights and you know how
how a nation state wants to control you
know people's sexuality or open up
controls previously held controls around
people's sexuality so i think for me the
the focus on um
gender is really an analytic focus like
how do we look at everything in the
world as having something to do with
gender right
just as
you know how do we think of everything
in the world or every process that's
going on in the world as being
racialized
you know that we don't you know race
is not a kind of meta problem of sort of
neutral processes like
liberalism you know
but instead to know that liberalism is
built through racial ideas and ideas
about race and the classic sort of
english framers of liberalism are
theorizing political political democracy
at the same time as they're thinking
through property relations
in a context in which slaves are not con
are considered to be property and not
humans so we have to understand
democracy as something that is already
built on certain social and cultural
foundations
that have at their base racial and
gendered
divisions
and that's really
i that's that's an important variable to
calculate of race and gender within all
the different
constructs and aspects of of society so
what have been some of the important
takeaways and learnings from looking at
things in that through that lens
well i mean i think
you know one
one uh
perhaps becomes thought of as an
iconoclast but if if if we say it often
enough i think it it starts to be
recognized as as true but
so you know i think one of the things in
this country that
um
often happens is that people want to
ignore
race or they want to see racial
discrimination as
sort of an individual
failing or an individual problem and not
a systemic and structural
issue that has a historical context
right so people want to say for example
that we're post-racial
right
um and i think if you if you take a long
historical and anthropological
view of political history and global
political economy then what you actually
come out with is okay all of our modern
institutions
are forged in the crucible
of racism and racial discrimination and
the transatlantic slave trade if we're
thinking about the western world right
and if that's so
that means that our contemporary
political institutions economic
institutions etc are all coming out of
that infrastructure that was created
you know from 1492
onward and so we can't escape it we have
to think about it and we have to
confront it and we have to track it not
in a linear way you know oh because of
this slave law in 16 whatever now we
have this it's not like that but to
understand that all of our modern
institutions are really rooted in that
history means that we can look at
different kinds of solutions that are
structural and systemic rather than just
individualizing the problems that we
face today yeah yeah
what would be some of the
some of the some of the good solutions
that you have in mind for us to
to
to be
there's a root level the root level
causes of some of the systemic issues
that we have what are some of your
solutions to some of those
i think you know
so many people propose the important
solutions we already know them you know
it's like massive structural change that
will actually equalize opportunity
for everybody right
and certainly
um
you know funding for education funding
for for
kids to have after school programs you
know leveling the playing field creating
pipelines i mean this is stuff everybody
knows and you know people choose to do
or or not do and certainly there are
diversity programs in pretty much every
corporation now and then we see the kind
of changes with respect to sexual
harassment policy i mean people people
know what to do
it's
uh what you know structurally and
systematically people know what to do so
it's a choice to do it or not do it but
i think on the interpersonal level too
um you know
that is more difficult and that requires
a different kind of commitment and it
requires a commitment to having
diverse
social
groups
you know
and i think despite everything most
people don't you know most people kind
of stick with
people they understand and people they
know and it turns out that their social
collectives aren't quite as racially
diverse as the country is for example
and so i think
you know there's the sort of internal
experiential psychological side of
racism or gender discrimination that
really takes a lot of
internal psychological work and
interpersonal
work and that has to happen alongside
the structural changes
you know in order to create the broader
change because you know as we see with
governments and shifting policies
policies change
and maybe um
maybe things open up
you know but
people's minds change a lot slower
so i think and that's
i think what we see today in in this
country too is a kind of backlash
against some of the structural changes
that have happened because people's
minds and hearts haven't changed yeah
it's a deep
process of getting into our hearts
it's deep it's a deep long consciousness
shift yeah yeah i'm sure what about
these books that you authored
political life in the wake of the
plantation
modern blackness
and also um co-editor of globalization
race
wha what
are what are really important oh
exceptional violence as well
what are the thesis of these books yeah
well modern blackness is really an
adaptation of my dissertation
so you know the answer to that already
exceptional violence came out of um
something that happened in the in the
community
uh that's you know one of the focus
sites
in modern blackness
where that had been the community where
i used to live and that had been a
community where members of both
political parties live side by side
without problem
and in jamaica there's a kind of long
history of political violence
between the parties that gets mobilized
especially at election time
and during the 1970s that political
distinction was mapped onto broader cold
war distinctions and it became a kind of
communist versus capitalist
sort of argument
that obviously has dissipated
with the end of the cold war
and yet this kind of system of political
um
curry favoring you know persists right
anyway so this community was one in
which
it was not a homogeneous community
politically and people had strong
relationships across the political
boundaries and it had always been like
that and there are some communities like
that in
in jamaica and
the basically the week
that modern blackness was released there
was a gang war that developed in the
community that sort of developed along
these political party lines linked with
other communities in
kingston and one of the kids
that was in a theater group that i had
developed while i was doing my field
research was killed in this in this war
so that book emerged from my
investigation into how how and why would
this have happened now
when you know for 40 years this has been
a peaceful community you know what is it
that
made this kind of violence flare up in
this community at this time and what is
the history of that violence you know
because when we experience these moments
of exceptional violence hence the title
sometimes they seem like sudden and
unexplained
flare-ups and like they come out of
nowhere you know and so in that book i'm
trying to show well it comes out of a
much longer history of violence
and to track what that history is and
how it continues to circulate both
structurally and through popular culture
music novels films etc and so there's
you know there are there are things that
catalyze a kind of flare
but the conditions are always there you
know and to talk about that as the
history of the west right in the legacy
of the west
uh the
volume globalization and race came out
sort of out of a conversation with a
friend of mine who's the co-editor of
the volume kamari clark
just wanting to bring together a number
of scholars who were thinking about
those issues you know there had been a
lot of
scholarship at the time about
globalization
and what that what
what that meant you know what what it
looked like
what the effects were economically you
know and politically and also in terms
of people moving all over the globe to
find work or keep work and corporations
moving all over the globe to find
cheaper costs and cheaper labor and
so there was a lot of scholarship on
globalization
very little of which was really attuned
to
um
you know what was going on in terms of
racial dynamics you know was this
exacerbating already existing equalities
or
is there potential for overcoming some
of the racial problems that have
happened so we just wanted to bring
together a number of scholars who are
working on those issues in different
sites
to sort of
see what kind of kind of conversation
you know that would be and so that
conversation ended up being about being
an edited volume and with articles
chapters from all of these other
scholars and then we wrote a framing
essay as the introduction
did globalization end up
exacerbating racism or decreasing it
ameliorating it
uh you know
everything is complicated right so in
some
you know what i see or what i was seeing
at the time in my own research was
um
that you know
on a structural level if we're looking
at indicators you know as the state
retreats from
uh investing in certain social
goods like education healthcare etc etc
it makes people who are already
precarious more precarious so on that
level it has a
deleterious you know
effect and whoever is already
marginalized within a population becomes
more marginalized and that's usually
black folk right
um
and poor whites you know but in
different ways
at the same time
in my little corner of the world you
know what was going on
was that
the people who were
coming of age around the time of
independence
they were in that community
dependent on
middle class people for access to
certain things
jobs
letters of invitation to a school a
better school for their kid um
you know um
admission to a loan service or you know
things like that that middle class
people served as the happily you know in
in a committed way served as brokers for
the working-class people in that
community
what that meant was you know there was a
tightness of relations you know across
class but it also meant that they had to
perform their class roles you know
there was a deference that was expected
to the middle class people in order to
uh
convince them to act on on their behalf
you know and i don't say that that the
relationship was false it wasn't false
but
it required a certain kind of class
organization right
so
fast forward you know 30 40 years those
people are now in their 60s or you know
in the 90s and 2000s or in their 60s
their children have migrated
largely i mean migration increased
exponentially and partly it's because
people need to go elsewhere to realize
their economic dreams or you know to get
the education that they want to get or
get the job that they want to get so
there's a push you know for the
migration
but it also means that now these
migrated children are sending
back money remittances they're sending
back goods they're sending back clothes
and so their parents who had previously
been dependent on the local middle class
are now getting what they need from
their kids who are abroad very
interesting so it means that they don't
have to do that deference
anymore
right so it's complicated right so you
know they're now sort of more autonomous
more self-sufficient
what that also means is that the ties
that bound classes together in the
community have weakened oh wow and it
means that some of the middle class
people stopped being involved in
community affairs there was more fear
and suspicion on both sides you know so
all of these things have very you know
not only double-edged swords but like
quadruplets
yeah
whoa so um a family can have uh
some of its offspring go overseas to
maybe a more economically prosperous
area earn money send it back home and
then the family
they have stronger ties to maybe the
middle class
for just just into just integration wise
now they can
as a lower class can step their economic
stage up and then create potentially
weaken those ties between the yeah very
very interesting
so these are the
these are these are the interesting
stories of globalization that i don't
think get discussed often enough well
because people are dealing with policy
people are dealing with macroeconomic
issues people are dealing with numbers
you know and i think the beauty of
anthropology is that you're really
getting at the nitty gritty because
you're following people
you know and you're trying to understand
the intimacies of people's social world
so
you know your numbers
aren't big in terms of what other social
scientists would call a sample size you
know
but um but the depth of the relationship
and the length of time that one spends
working on these issues generates a sort
of
a very complex
um you know
i was going to say bird's eye view but
it's not that really it's a you know a
complex emic perspective on on what the
effects of some of these big macro
processes are and it allows us to
understand the very complex and
sometimes contradictory effects that
processes have so that we're not
surprised
you know when it when when they kind of
turn into
policy events you know
yeah so then there's almost a
there's a benefit from a very bird's-eye
perspective on how resources are flowing
and what it what's going on between
maybe two countries but then there's
also a
very large benefit to going into having
a just behind someone's eyes
individually with their family and their
relationship with people around them and
then all of a sudden you're actually
learning that their
offspring is making more money in the
place sending the money that kind of
thing yeah and to see that those stories
are different in different places you
know there's no one
effect of globalization you know it
looks different here from there from
there from there so there's no
one sort of policy universal
that's going to make sense
everywhere or even in sort of
humanitarian
efforts for example
you know if one really looks at as many
anthropologists do
really looks at you know how that works
in ex location or y location you know
you see it's very different so imposing
a policy solution you know across
territory without regard for local
differences historical differences etc
you know it doesn't work
sadly policy makers don't don't consult
anthropologists that often that would be
that's a very powerful uh combination of
policy makers and anthropologists policy
makers like ethicists there's there
there's a lot of important combinations
uh artificial intelligence engineers and
ethicists or anthropologists you know
these yeah yeah
and anthropologists do work on all that
stuff yes i mean that's what's
uh nice about the field is it's very
broad it's very eclectic it's a big
giant tent it is yes i and i i feel very
at home here feels very good because i'm
such a multi-disciplinary person this is
a very multi-disciplinary show we say
we're disciplinarily promiscuous
interdisciplinarily promiscuous
yesterday i was called an undercover
anthropologist
yeah
disciplinarily promiscuous that is so
funny i love that
i love that uh
yeah that's that's a good one i want to
what was it would be the one with like
with uh
like
disciplinarily polyamorous or something
something like that yeah um okay let's
let's ask you about your about
relationships with teaching because as
you teach you have students and you
teach them across this information you
know you're learning from them they're
learning from you
what have been some cool takeaways for
you from this process for me yeah um
different at the undergraduate level
from the graduate level of course at the
undergraduate level
um
i mean it's just really beautiful to see
that light bulb turn on
you know and to see it happen in the
classroom to see someone find their
passion
you know which doesn't happen like all
the time you know not everybody wants to
be an anthropologist or have that kind
of a take
excuse me have that kind of a take on
the on the world but um
when you see it it is lovely you know
and we do have
a couple i have had undergraduates both
at duke and uh penn who are now my
colleagues here you know who got bit by
the bug that's so cool you know
now they're here they're your students
here they're they're professors
elsewhere they're now teaching their own
students you know which is quite lovely
but if even they don't go into
anthropology once that light bulb turns
on you know they could take it in any
field you know the students who are
filmmakers now or who are artists or
you know who are doctors or you know but
they have a sensibility that they carry
with them which is nice grad students
are different um
i learn
always a ton from my grad students and
the kind of intellectual and social
relationships we have are really
valuable
to me because
you know
we're working through material together
i have more experience at it than they
do but they always bring fresh insights
to stuff i think i already know yeah you
know and and i learned from their
research projects you know when they're
out in the world doing their field work
and they're sending back
you know monthly this is what i did this
month and these are the questions that
have come up or when they're thinking it
through when they're writing their
dissertation and you get to read it
you know it's
you learn
about you know i don't do research in
west africa but i feel like i know quite
a lot about it from students who are
working there or
you know other parts of the world and
that i think is
you know really lucky i literally pinch
myself every week and say i can't
believe
that people pay me you know to do
something that i love yeah i was i was
loving how you were explaining that
graduate students will send you a
summary of what they're working on and
you get to just like
dive into what they care about in that
moment you're learning about where
they're at what they're doing
a couple quick thoughts
you have some films that you've worked
on
and then you have the experimental
ethnography center now center for
experimental ethnography
i want to know something
that i think we talk about on the show
decent amount but it's
geopolitics and i'm curious what you've
seen with
china's investment into
jamaica the caribbean africa
what have you been because the relation
china africa relations are very
interesting um and there seems to be a
big geopolitical push for who is going
to be supplying
the growing economies with their socks
and
toothpaste
underwear
stuff like that well and who is the new
um
you know political entity that's
extracting minerals and right because
that's yeah i mean in many african
countries that's the
principal
reason for chinese investment and others
it's infrastructure development it's
roads it's hospitals in the caribbean
it's mostly infrastructural development
and
toward a diplomatic
agenda which is um to get more caribbean
countries to recognize the prc rather
than taiwan because there are a number
of caribbean countries that are still
allied to taiwan so every caribbean
country gets a vote in the u.n and the
prc has a one china policy
so that some of their activity in the
caribbean is really geared toward that
diplomatic shift that they want to see
happen
in jamaica well throughout latin america
and the caribbean there's a
long-standing chinese presence there are
a lot of chinese who came over in the
late
late 19th century early 20th century as
migrant laborers
in jamaica many of them
went into retail grocery
made a variety of innovations into that
field
became the shopkeepers in every rural
town
in jamaica and subsequently developed a
kind of monopoly on the bakery
industries and other kinds of industries
so there's a long-standing community
in jamaica so this new
group of chinese who are coming over
it's created some interesting dynamics
because on one hand
you know what it also represents is a
decline of u.s investment in jamaica
especially after the financial crash in
2008
and so where the u.s diminished their
investments china stepped up and that
sort of
you know was part of the beginning of a
process where you were seeing more and
more chinese interest
they have invested in the bauxite
industry in jamaica which is the raw
material for creating aluminum whoa and
that's always been a kind of contentious
who controls boxes in jamaica is very
important and the us was very interested
in the 1940s and 50s because of the
korean war and they were requiring you
know closer aluminum stores
than what they were getting it from
before so
um you know so on the other hand on one
hand it's an opportunity
there's like infrastructure development
like you were saying is it but then
there's also a new road that's you know
beautiful that was built by the by the
chinese so on one hand it's an economic
opportunity for the country
um to court this investment and see you
know what kinds of alliances can be made
on the other hand people experience it
as many people experience it as a kind
of new imperialism not the same
political imperialism that european
countries did and that the sort of
you know soft and not so soft american
influence politically uh has been really
from the 60s onward
but uh an economic imperialism and one
that carries with it a kind of racism
people feel that they're being treated
poorly by
by a new chinese coming in so as with
every
new process it generates both
excitement and anxiety and so i think
it's
it is an interesting thing to follow
throughout latin america the caribbean
and africa right now because it really
speaks to a contemporary shift in terms
of the global political economy and
moves us you know moves us into a very
new dispensation you know away from the
kind of dominance of the west
towards something else that's going on
and we don't know where that's going to
end up right yeah yeah
geopolitical malleability and yeah yeah
um last thought about the current state
of humanity and about maximizing human
potential what do you think
oh what do i think about maximizing
human potential uh what i think is that
i can only have an impact on that in my
own small world so i tried to maximize
the human potential of my students
my undergrad students my grad students
and certainly my own children yes try to
give them
you know the opportunities to think big
you know and to and to
to be curious and to really investigate
a question until
you get to the end of that road and
sometimes that road takes a long time to
get to the end of so for many
you know for all of us who become
anthropologists i mean these are
lifelong questions in a way you're
constantly trying to answer
a different iteration of the same
question that you started out with
because each step you take you get a
little further down the road yeah yeah
thank you so much for joining us on the
show this has been very enriching and
there's still so much more to understand
thanks debra thank you thank you such a
pleasure thanks everyone for tuning in
we'd love to hear your thoughts in the
comments below also check out deborah's
bio and link down below also triple a's
link down below give them a look
and go and build the future manifest
your destiny into the world everyone
thanks for tuning in and we'll see you
soon peace
thank you
that was so fun that was fun
boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation i'm your host alan sakyon we
are on site at the american anthropo
anthropological we're going to redo that
all right